welcome ed sheeran
[Applause]
it's wonderful
so great to be here man
[Applause]
now you're now you're here uh with uh
sherry and with peter storm and uh and
also you met a lot of famous people for
the last uh 10 years of your of your
life
uh what would you say is the weirdest
situation that fame has put you so far
uh oh mate so many situations i once i
once i once was with someone um and his
uh with their entourage and um i
we were just in a club and it had a
shower in it and a hot tub and just kind
of turned around and he was naked
i know him a bit i remember looking at
his entourage and being like
and everyone's just kind of on their
phone like this and he's just kind of
there and he's naked and he's sort of
walking around doing stuff has a shower
gets in the hot tub naked gets out the
shower gets out the hot tub sort of
carries on walking around naked i
remember being like
is anyone no one thinks he's sweating
and then he put on his clothes and then
like the night resumed but i just yeah i
mean that was quite a strange situation
i won't say who it is but
would i know who it is yeah yeah
everyone everyone would know everyone
okay so it's it's like it's prince
be funny if it was prince charles if it
was but yeah
what's the weirdest situation you've
been in
i i remember that we had adele
and
you know her of course
and my plan was to make her
sing
and my uh smart idea was that i i wanted
her to sing a lullaby to demonstrate how
does a lullaby sound
you know i'm sure that went down very
well it didn't it didn't well
it ended with her forcing
she was forcing me to sing lullabies for
her
so it was like a lose-lose for everyone
i kind of you should i kind of feel a
bit left out i feel like i need a
lullaby now we need a lot of by now
[Applause]
no i can't do that
is that the one you do
no i sing what do i say i sing uh i grew
up with like traditional folk music so
i'll sing like um
i guess like like raglan road like um on
raglan road on an autumn day i saw her
first i knew but like really just try it
just tell me
i
i don't think i should follow up now
with a lot of houses
come on i think we move on
but what would you say
looking back on the i mean it's ten
years it's sort of a celebration of that
and and i think that
looking back now what kind of memory is
stick more the more the real life stuff
like the real
life moments i got married to my wife in
a tiny tiny chapel with pretty much no
one there and we lit loads of candles
and it was like the middle of january
really cold dark outside and we just got
married at night went back and had a
curry and that's like the most like real
memory i have and then holding my child
for the first time and stuff like that
in my 10 years i feel like they're the
memories that will stick forever but
when you when i think about career i can
you know there are obviously things that
are fun but did they matter as much in
the long run you know
in
in one of your new songs
and it's called first times
uh there you you sing about your
greatest achievement yeah and it's not
80 000 people at wembley no
tell me about it uh
well i feel like i feel like the great
the greatest achievement i've made is
starting a family having having love in
my life i feel i know so many people
that have so many things that have
filled up their house or like they have
lots of money or they've had lots of
success but
they're lonely and they they wish for
that and i've had moments of my career
where
you know i i play solo i come off stage
i sit in a dressing room and it's like
oh i've got no one to share this i've
got no one celebrate with this with you
can have all the accolades in the world
but if you've got no one to celebrate
the success with like what's what's the
point so i'd say the greatest success
has been
settling and finding someone that
uh she's very very unspotlighted you
know she doesn't ever want to do red
carpet she's not on instagram she's not
like good i know
yes
he is no
i'm not though i don't i don't trust
anyone that likes red carpets jimmy do
you like if you meet someone this summer
but you are on instagram
yeah but i don't really i'm if you look
at my instagram i'm not posting a selfie
every day i post about songs i'm like
promoting stuff and if i if i post
everything is to promote stuff and when
i've got nothing to promote i'm off i'm
i'm not i don't know you you you're
using them they're not using you in a
way instagram is a promotional tool that
is the point of of instagram and i
i feel like
i feel like when you're sucked into it
and you're you're in this world of um do
you know how i how i put it like my
whenever i see a selfie
i want to reach out to that person and
be like are you having an all right day
because that is them wanting they're
having a [__] day and they want people
to be like oh my god you look amazing
and that'll make them that'll bring them
up and it's never but it's not it's not
it's quite a serious serious thing i
think like instagram it has this like
not even i'm not ragging on instagram
social media in general has this like
sheen of like life is perfect and it
makes everyone else feel like [__]
because they're like well why isn't my
life perfect but really the person
behind the thing posting the perfect
life is having a [__] day and they want
people to be like oh my god this is
great and it's it's all smoking mirrors
basically so i i use it as a i'm like
here's my song this is my video but
other than that but i i i i i read about
it somewhere that
uh i read that you you don't even have a
phone i don't have a phone no i haven't
had a phone system yeah actually i heard
that too yeah
no but it's true i i don't i don't have
a phone i bought i had to why why did
you quit having a phone
because i found myself in situations
like real life situations where even if
i was if i didn't even if i wasn't
answering a text or even like i would
have like a phone on the table even if
it was in my pocket i'd be having a
conversation with you like this and it
would vibrate and my mind would not be
in the conversation it'd be good it
would go oh who was that i wonder who
that was do you reckon it's this person
what do you reckon they said until i
take it out my pocket and then i answer
the text and then suddenly our moment
has ended and i'm in this and now i find
that there's no connection to anything
people can't reach me i can't be
interrupted i go to dinner with my wife
i go to dinner with my dad i go for
lunch with my friends and i'm in it and
i'm having a conversation and i see my
friends all the time suddenly come out
of the conversation it's just
i don't know like
kids nowadays grow up with it and i i
guess when it's integrated into your
life like that it's fine but you
remember a time where you didn't have a
phone i do too you do too you do
and
you can live without it you can i have
an email and i answer the email whenever
the [__] i want to answer the email
[Applause]
you know what i hate
i hate the um
the instant you you someone texts you
and you text them back and then the
bubbles come up and they text you back
and you go [__] i don't i haven't got
time for this and then suddenly you're
like in this conversation and you're re
you're rude if you don't text back
whereas with email
out of office man did you get a text
yeah two minutes later did you get my
text but but email if you aren't i
answer usually on a sunday night and i
put them all in my draft and then at
sunday
morning you know monday morning each
time about 1 am i send them all out so
no one can reply
and then throughout the week people
reply so so if i if i wanted to ask you
to come sing in my
wedding
let's say i should marry yeah
then i should send an email
yeah but not to me
[Laughter]
does it is that just my wedding or any
wedding you don't do that mate i would
actually i my rule with with weddings
i've kind of become
i don't know
but if i'm going to do it i'll do it for
free and i'll turn up if i want to turn
up the last one i did was ronan keating
the singer and i bumped into him in a
bar in new york with his fiancee and
they said will you play our wedding and
i was like if i'm free turned out i was
and
ended up doing it it's good
did you sing in your own money uh no
[__] no
no no my my own wedding um my own
wedding was a really small affair i made
the playlist the night before um we had
a tiny tent and i'm talking like minimum
minimal people cherry's dad my wife
cooked a curry and then we put on the
playlist and we had a dance and then we
were probably in bed by like midnight um
i had a wedding party that was a bit
more raucous but i don't really remember
much of that because i just said hi and
bye to people
hi thanks for coming hi thanks for
coming bye thanks
but that that brave moment when you
decide that now it's the time to propose
oh my god [__] what what what
happened there well cherry's parents
never married
so they were together for 30 years
they're now they've now married by the
way but they they were together for 30
years so she hasn't grown up in
thinking that marriage is important but
i've come from a
that sort of thing and my parents are
married their parents married and blah
blah so i was walking into it being like
i don't know if she's going to say yes
there wasn't like a
you know the confidence of being like
hey oh my god yes so i did it so you you
really didn't know really didn't know i
remember getting down on what i've never
told this story actually i remember
getting down on one knee
and her just being like
and i was like
marry me and she was like you're [__]
joking and i remember there was just a
just a long silence and i just went
please
that was the most human that i've ever
felt the most because it was like in my
career sometimes i
you know you find i'd be like can i do
this and people will just be like yeah
well can i do this and yeah you kind of
get to a certain point where it just
becomes normal and then you're in a
situation where you are literally on
your knees being like
yeah and it's such a huge life decision
that someone has to make in the blink of
an eye thankfully she did say yes and uh
you know
did you have a plan b there
the worst thing about it was i put the
[__] date on the ring
so i and the day and it was pissing it
down with rain outside and i'd built a
[__] pergola at the end of the garden
do you get to do it sun sunset go to the
pergola some wine and it's pissing it
down with rain and i kept saying to her
we should go for a walk she's like no
you sure you don't want to go for a walk
and time's ticking time's ticking
and there's the date on the ring and i'm
like i've got to do it today because
then it's like it gets to like 9 p.m and
what i'm [__] saying then yeah this is
the first time i've ever told this
[Laughter]
story it's fantastic
look
i understood
from reading about you that you had you
had a break during the pandemic you also
had a break from songwriting you you
actually you quit
yeah i did start i did stop songwriting
i didn't quit i was i was considering i
wasn't considering retirement i was
considering retiring from giving a [__]
does that make sense
so like you know like you act right and
you take
roles that you really want to do and
sometimes you take roles that you know
that can further your career you know
and i
at some point you just stop going
like i
you know you would if you if you want to
write a song you write a song but maybe
you don't release it you know but some i
feel like i have to release songs
sometimes so i i sort of just stepped
back from it and
uh didn't touch guitar i didn't do
anything i was just being dead and um
then i like slowly got back into it and
i got very sad when i didn't do music
because music's my hobby and you find i
mean music then becomes your job and
then so it didn't it didn't do you well
to have that break
no because it's your hobby i do it every
day because i love it i don't do it
every day because i get paid for it i do
it every day because i love it and in my
head i'd kind of been like this is my
job so you have to take a break from
your job and then i took a break from my
hobby and got really sad who turned you
who got you to to start again start up
again
depression
i'd say that yeah
okay
so so the life of a pensioner was not
for you they know it wasn't even that i
just got i just got sad i just got i i
i'm prone to and i think all all
creatives are prone to real
ups and downs because you have a part of
your brain that you open to write a song
that you let these really personal
emotions out to write the song but then
that part doesn't close sometimes so you
are just you ha you feel so much and you
are up and down and up and down and my
highs are really high but my lows are
really really low and i got really low
and realized that the thing that made me
happy was writing songs and getting
those feelings out again did you did you
manage to
still be uh a a a great father in that
situation
was that did you find that more
difficult than you thought
well um
yeah i think i've always been
i've always been
like present and and there but i do
think yeah like
being sad
around your kids
is never a nice thing is it
that's not music cheaper than a shrink
it really is i've never i've never i've
never had i've never had a therapist
i've never had a therapist whenever i
feel like [__] because my hobby is to
write music i don't get it out of you
don't you you get it you get it out and
it's it's the best best thing to do
anything any major thing that happens in
my life that brings me down the most
positive thing i can do from that is is
write a song like my i have a song
called you need me i don't need you all
right when i was 15 years old and it was
my first batch bout with the music
industry and people were like you'll
never make it no one i'll show you and i
wrote a song about it and from an
experience of feeling down i then had
this
like song that had come out of it and
now any time i feel down i write a song
and out of a [__] situation comes a
great song that then lasts forever and
it helps other people listen to that and
go oh he was in a [__] situation i'll
get out of so it's it is a form of
therapy
and i wasn't doing that so i just
suddenly stopped talking to something
which was a bit of paper and a pen and
all your thoughts and feelings come back
in so how did you get started your
inspiration from the beginning from the
beginning um i uh i grew up listening to
bands where where are you from really in
i'm from suffolk
have you been yes have you
yeah i have to please
i was living in london for like two
years and somehow somewhere i just ended
up there with some friends it was three
days i don't know why i was there
i still live there yeah my wife's from
there we went to the same high school
with all of our friends there it's like
but you did live in l.a for a while
where he lives yeah i lived in los
angeles again got quite sad in los
angeles but more so have you read um uh
the philip pullman books northern lights
have anyone read them
and it might so my daughter is named
after the um uh heroine from from that
but in the book it's all about parallel
worlds right and there's a knife that
can cut into parallel worlds and you can
go into any world you want but if you
spend more than a certain time there you
die and your heart gets sad and and you
die and i find los angeles is a parallel
world to england and i go there
and i live there for a bit and i'm like
this is great and then you start to get
sad and sad and you miss home and then
you go back home and your juice re
reflow so now i i'm very this is why i
love living in suffolk i am
unreachable when i want to be
unreachable and i dip into places when i
want to dip in so if i want to go and do
a red carpet or an award show i'll fly
over and then i'll fly back i'm not like
there the whole time does that make
sense this is the same as oslo yeah yeah
i started guitar because i saw eric
clapton on the queen's jubilee play
layla oh and i picked up a guitar that
that day and then in all honestly no one
wanted to be in a band with me as a kid
so i would know all these riffs and i've
played in a band for a bit
but then i went to go and see damian
rice in concert and i saw
one man on stage with an acoustic guitar
kill it for two hours and it had
everyone in the palm of his hand and i
remember looking at that being like oh
i don't need a band you can just get an
acoustic guitar and you can control a
stage so that was that was the guy that
really i was like i'm going to write
songs i'm going to be a singer
songwriter wow tell me sorry yeah i was
just going to ask you but you're a huge
hip-hop fan too right or what i've
noticed how
how is that why is that um i had a
stutter as a kid i had a really really
bad stutter um i had a birthmark which
is still kind of there and uh it was
gonna turn into something nastier when i
was older so i got it i got it lasered
off and they didn't put any anesthetic
on they forgot to so as a kid i forgot
it was
nhs and uh i uh
so all of my primary school was me
talking like that and i went to speech
therapy i had homeopathy i had
everything but i was recommended by my
uncle
jim
my man uh he bought me an m m record and
he said learn this then this this guy
raps fast i bet you can't do this and so
i learned all of it and my stutter
slowly went and then i've just been sort
of immersed in that from from that age
listening to everything do you see do
you see yourself
go on forever like abba they're coming
back now yeah it's like
i went to my friend's 30th the other day
and before 11 p.m gimme gimme gimme was
played three times
buy a dj buy a dj
like that it's still haven't ever agree
um no i see myself going on forever but
i see it being what i said you retire
from giving a [__] at a certain point
you go right like if i want to play a
show i'll play a show but i'm not gonna
tour for
four years i'm gonna i'm gonna turn up
in this city i'm going to play this
venue that i want to play and i'm going
to play it for two nights because i want
to play it for two nights and i've
written a song do i want to release it
nah i think that's the point i want to
be i want to still always be creative
and still always playing but there's a
point where and that's not gonna happen
for a while i have like real drive and i
love what i do and i love playing gigs i
love touring i love releasing but there
will become a point where
i i don't think i have the drive to be
uh successful
singer-songwriter but i will have the
drive just to be a singer-songwriter
that just likes writing songs i think so
that will go on forever you will yeah
always always because it's therapy do
you think that your
if you if you look at your own traits
are they which ones are from your mom
and which ones are from your dad
uh
mate my mom is a saint like she is an
absolute warm golden angel so if i've
got any i would love to say i've got
traits from her because we've been
talking about that we all have mom
oh man she's like i i hope i've got my
mum's traits i can't say i've got my
mum's straights because she hasn't got
any bad traits so i think she does like
gin i like gin so
but you know like i think uh i think
from my dad my dad always instilled like
work ethic in me and
timing
he was all i could never be late never i
always finished what was on my plate to
be polite you'd never be late because
you're you have to respect other
people's time it's not about your time
you have to risk but being late is not
you being it's that's not your time
you've eaten into that's someone else's
time so he taught me that and always
he was like you might never be the best
at something but you can always work
harder than someone who is the best and
i took that and i came into an industry
where i am not the most talented person
in my industry but i know i can outwork
everyone because that that's the one
thing i can do so when i got in
i said to atlantic records when i signed
i was like who's the hardest working
person on your books and they said james
blunt and i said get me his diary from
his busiest year and we will do that
plus more and that's what we did for our
first year and it worked and so the next
time we did more and the next time we
did more i'm signing cds at the moment
i've signed 115 000 cds to just to make
sure that i've done 30 000 of one single
30 000 single 38 000 of the album i'm
just like
i've i get an obsession in my head with
wanting to be the hardest worker how's
your hand
uh they said practice
but but
if you were to choose one trait in
yourself that you don't want your
daughter to inherit what would that be
uh
i think the ability to have real loads i
would hate for my daughter to have
and i know she will because it runs in
my family i think it's
yeah
i would hate for my daughter to feel
sad and not know the reason why
do you think that famous changed you
do you know
yeah and i don't [__] care like i'm
thirsty like like i have so many people
that i knew when i was like 17 18
they're like you're you've changed i'm
like i'm 30. like even if i wasn't a
celebrity i'd i'd have changed i think
yeah i've
i think what fame is is it is an
enhancer of anything that is going on if
you have an ego you get a bigger bigger
ego if you're anxious you get more
anxious if you're shy you get more shy
and
i look at my dad and my dad has four
friends now and they're like his core
friends and he probably had 20 friends
when he was 20 or 25
but the older you get the smaller your
friendship group shrinks and fame just
speeds that up it just enhances that so
my friendship group has shrunk but i'm
left with the people that i'd been left
with in 20 years anyway so yeah i have
changed um
i've learned a lot and i i don't care
what people think like i'm i'm
i'm so happy with where i am i love my
friends i love my wife i love my family
and um
yeah
change is seen in the industry any any
industry is such a like dirt dirty word
like oh they're gonna change it's like
no you change everyone around you
changes which makes me change and then
i'm suddenly in a position where i get
blamed for their insecurities
it's wonderful to have you on the show
thank you so much
hope you enjoyed the clip for more
interesting conversations please hit
subscribe
you